ومشاهدينا هذه صور مباشره للاحتجاجات التي
تشهدها فرنسا اذا هذه الصور المباشره
لمسيره في ضاحيه غرب باريس فقد اعلن ايضا
اليوم مشاهدينا وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
ومن قوات الدرك ايضا لحفظ النظام العام
الليله مع استمرار اعمال العنف بسبب مقتل
شاب
بالرصاص الشرطه وزير الخارجيه مشاهدينا
قال ان من بين هؤلاء سينشروا خمسه الاف في
باريس وحدها الحفظ النظام العام وايضا
مشاهدينا في غضون ذلك رئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
كان مدد باعمال العنف هذه
والممارسه خاصه ضد رموز الجمهوريه وذلك
طبعا في اشاره الى المؤسسات الحكوميه
والمدارس وكذلك مراكز الشرطه
الرئيس الفرنسي امام مقروء ايضا مشاهدينا
قال خلال تراسه
اجتماعا لخليه الازمه الحكوميه قال ان
اعمال العنف التي اعقبت مقتل الشاب على يد
الشرطه امر لا يمكن تبريره ونواصل معكم
متابعه هذه الصور المباشره لمسيره في
ضاحيه
غربا باريس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات